hello kiddies welcome to convocation I
know there are other people than the
kiddies watching but we don't care about
them
conversation is complication it's going
to be like everything we do here right
now which is means as normal as possible
except of course you're not here na
nananana there are a few of us here in
the chapel and it's beautiful and it's
empty alas you'll see the team the deans
and the academic authorities back there
and the chaplain and I want you to
notice that they're all standing 6 feet
apart because nobody wants to be
arrested by the governor and also Matt
young and Chris Van Orman mathematically
astute have measured to make sure there
will be no spreading of the virus right
now some of the conversations is going
to be streamed we hope that that will be
seamless we hope that you'll be unable
to tell except for one thing and that is
we're putting a subtitle or a caption on
the places that are pre-recorded so we
won't get in trouble with the governor
we have been observing all the protocols
around here and complaining about them
and complaining I will say is different
than whining because it's supposed to be
constructive and we miss you and this is
a great ceremony and I hope you since
its greatness where you are as much as
you do normally when you're here thank
you for watching
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let us pray Heavenly Father we thank you
for bringing us safely to this day for
giving us the opportunity to study the
highest Goods in peace and for blessing
us with rich friendships and
partnerships in the pursuit of virtue we
thank you that you not left us alone but
have given us each other to spur us on
to goodness we thank you that you have
not left us comfortless but have given
us your very self and the person of your
son Jesus Christ's to atone for our
failures to make straight the path to
your embrace and to enliven us with his
holy spirit who lives within us Lord God
we lament that we are not able to
physically gather to get together today
and while we give thanks to you for the
creative industry of human engineers and
the technological prowess which allow us
to close the distance which separates us
even just a little we acknowledge that
it's just not the same as life together
as we are our custom - we ask you Lord
that you would bring us back together
soon and that you would continue to
foster affection between us even as we
are spread abroad prepare also that you
would rid our nation of this pestilence
of disease bless our medical
professionals heal the sick comfort
their families and bring us all to
fullness of health I guess also that you
would make us humble in the midst of
this crisis that we may use it wisely to
examine our lives to acknowledge our
sinfulness to seek here atoning embrace
above all else and to grow in a
disposition which instinctively gives
thanks to you in all circumstances
finally Lord we ask for your blessing on
today's proceedings may the words of our
mouths and the thoughts of our hearts be
acceptable in your sight who are our
rock and our Redeemer and all this we
beg for Jesus Christ's sake our only
mediator and add
amen please face the flag and say the
Pledge with me I pledge allegiance to
the flag of the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the spring
convocation a special thanks to our
organist
dr. Derek Stav - Jim Holloman for
arranging the music Debbie wise the
Hillsdale College Choir and Chamber
Choir and - Reverend Adam Rick for the
invocation and benediction today we are
especially grateful to the Hillsdale
College marketing department and to the
digital team for all their hard work to
make today's event possible
distinguished member of the platform
party today are dr. Larry iron president
dr. mark call Toth Dean of faculty dr.
Matthew young Dean of the Natural
Sciences dr. Stephen Smith Dean of
humanities dr. Paul Marino Dean of
Social Sciences and Reverend Adam wreak
Havok Alice Chapman we are missing two
people from the platform this morning
dr. RJ post Rito graduate Dean who's
away on family business and dr. Lee
beard professor of chemistry and the
2019 professor of the year will bear
speaker today by video normally at the
ceremony the graduating seniors and the
graduate students are donned under
graduation robes and they process in
with the faculty with the convocation
with us is at this point of the program
that we ask each of you to stand and be
recognized so I know you're not present
with us today but I'm going to ask that
each of you stand any way wherever you
are please get up I know it seems a
little odd but I want you to stand up
please get up out of that chair you've
earned this this moment is a fitting
tribute to the high purpose in which we
have been engaged for so long be proud
of your accomplishments the friendships
you developed keep in mind that you will
always be the senior class that overcame
even this isolation from one another and
still rose to the challenge in order to
graduate we are so very proud of each
and every one of you you may be seated
thanks for doing that at this time I'm
also pleased to announce the top 10
graduating seniors in alphabetical order
please also stand as I read your name
Sarah Becker
Natalie Bodnar Jessica Chen Emma Clifton
Nathaniel gape
Olivia moly Sydney San Juan Hana
Stevenson Gabriella Van Aken and Kaitlyn
waiter your graduations to each of you
for your hard work and dedication you
may also be seated at this time next to
senior class officers are usually
recognized they come up the stage pass
the gavel to the next class so I want to
I want to recognize the 2020 current
officers president Adam Bookman vice
president Lucas Swenson secretary Reagan
cool treasurer Elizabeth leathers social
chair Hadiya Richie and the fundraising
chair Lucy Meckler and it is now my
honor to announce the newly elected
officers for 2021
they are president Brayden Van Dyke vice
president max troika secretary and
Catherine Daly treasurer Mika Perry
social chair Leanne agudo so I want to
thank the outgoing officers for their
leadership over the past year and offer
my congratulations to the newly elected
officers we look forward to working with
you now for the scholarship
announcements the all-school grade point
average for fall 2018 was a three point
three eight five the all-women's average
was a three point four eight four which
leaves the men's all average at a three
point two nine three the sorority
scholarship this year goes to Pi Beta
Phi with a GPA of 3.5 one eight and the
fraternity scholarship this year goes to
Sigma Chi with a GPA of three point two
four six congratulations to both houses
next it's my honor to introduce Larry P
Arnn
the 12th president of Hillsdale College
he received his BA from Arkansas State
University graduating with the highest
distinction
he received his MA and government and
his PhD in government from the Claremont
Graduate School he also studied in
England first as a research student in
international history at the London
School of Economics and then in modern
history at Oxford University while in
England he also served as director of
research for the
sir martin gilbert the official
biographer of winston churchill he
returned to the united states become
editor for public research syndicated
and he served as president of the
claremont institute an education and
research institution based in southern
california well a claremont he was the
founding chairman of the California
Civil Rights initiative which passed by
California voters in 1996 and prohibited
racial preference in state hiring
contracting and admissions dr. Arnn is
on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
Center of Claremont McKenna College the
intercollegiate Studies Institute and
the Claremont Institute he served on the
US Army War College Board of Visitors
for two years for which he earned the
Department of the Army's outstanding
civilian Service Medal in 2015 dr. armed
received the Bradley prize from the Lynn
and Harry Bradley Foundation he's a
member of the American Political Science
Association the International Churchill
Society the Mont Pelerin Society at the
Philadelphia society and the
philanthropic Artful oppler eak round
table published widely in national
newspapers magazines of periodicals on
issues of Public Policy history and
political theory is the author of three
books Liberty and learning the evolution
of American education
the founders key the divine and natural
connection because between the
Declaration and the Constitution and
what we risk by losing it and finally
Churchill's trial Winston Churchill and
the salvation of free government
dr. Arnn is his wife Penelope have four
children Katie
Henry Alice and Tony please help me in
welcoming dr. Larry our
I see those deans back there they look
like they don't get along anymore keepin
their distance thank you Chris
I love convocation and even this one and
normally a conversation I say a few
words about the state of the college and
a few words about the mission of the
college those last few words are always
about the same because the mission
doesn't change and today I have to say a
little bit about the situation too and
also what I expect for the few from the
future from this stupid situation I
think we've navigated pretty well
through it so far and that means I've
got special thanks to say I want to
thank the faculty it's been fun it's
amusing some of them are afraid of
technology and they've just got over
that in a hurry but it was amusing
because of course they're all you know
among the most intelligent people
walking they just never did that before
and they're learning to do it and they
like it and of course some of them take
to it like a duck to water and as far as
I can tell all of the students do
because I have got a favorite saying
people ask me sometimes do you teach
students to learn computers and I always
say if you can't figure out by yourself
how to use a computer you'll never learn
and that seems to be true of the young
the students you guys are great
every communication I have from a
student in my classes and many others is
inspiring more so than the average and
they're always inspiring it's one reason
we miss you because you're fun and we do
this together and you see the joy of it
and young are better expressing the joy
than we are so it's still great though
and you're working hard
under difficulty the Provost has
encouraged the faculty not to give you
longer to take your exams on the on the
argument that we know what you're like
you'll take them till you know two years
from now to get them perfect and we're
not striving for the
fect here except ultimately we're
striving for the better and so you
shouldn't fret more than you normally do
the faculty knows what's going on and
they will grade fairly and we will be so
proud of you for working so hard Chris
mentioned the audiovisual team it's
amazing we just put the operations of
this College online we had a head start
because we have these online courses
very many of them the numbers
registering for those are way up from
normal experience which was already high
but now we're doing just basically
everything that way and the people who
do it are skilled Mark Waters sitting
there in front of me and Jason Cheryl
runs the IT department and and you know
those guys are there's JW in the back
those guys are talented and they make
this work and I hope they're not making
glitches right now so I'll sound
ridiculous but probably they're not yeah
who else do I have to sing Erin
Karlovich organizes this convocation and
usually we're in a panic about the
seating because we want you all to seat
as close as possible and we're not
accustomed to seating in the chapel yet
but it's still a mess because you got to
figure out how to stream this thing and
there's been a lot of people working on
that there was mentioned the seniors at
spring convocation and Chris just did
and I'm gonna amplify his remarks
there's a real loss and it's worst for
you because this is the time it's so fun
for me to think about what you seniors
do in your last few weeks on the campus
because different emotions are running
and running more strongly than normal
you're going to leave you're tired a lot
of you come and want to give me your
advice about how to run the college I
enjoy that a lot and I learned from it
too and and you celebrate with each
other
and you profess your love for each other
and for us and you're not together to do
that so we have to turn the loss into a
good and we're going to do that we're
going to do it first each one of us in
exactly the way we've been doing it
we're going to work harder to have all
the good that's available here
commencement we have a plan that we
think might be better even than normal
so we've pulled you and we found out
that July the 18th is the best day and
we hope you'll come on the 16th and the
college is going to help you with your
travel cost and put you up and feed you
while you're here and put on some
parties I'm told senior class officers
and I'm very grateful to them by the way
because they've been good to work with
from the first day of their officialdom
also all year long and through this very
good and that's so you want something
that's like central hall Appaloosa and
so we're going to have something like
that and you want something like the
president's ball and so we're going to
have something like that and you want to
come over to our house for dinner and
we're going to have that right now it
looks like big tent across the street
cocktails on the front porch party after
in the back garden my wife's getting
ready for all that by the way she did
these flowers down here and as you can
see the woman has a grace about her
thank God
there's going to be a baccalaureate
service on commencement morning and then
the blue and white luncheon where we
introduce the top five and valid showing
the salutatorian I hope you don't know
who that is but it often leaks in other
words it's going to be normal except
everything is going to be focused on
that finals will not have just ended
they'll be over for a time now the pain
of them will have receded and we'll have
the joy of getting back together
and I think that'll make it more fun
than it's ever been and that's the
purpose now we have to have this
ceremony because in the ceremony I
always point out to the senior class
officers and they're always quick to
understand the ceremonies at the end of
the year are not just for the seniors
they're for everybody
they're an achievement that everybody
has one I always say it commencement
parents friends of the college faculty
students everybody who helps in loves to
college helps make this ceremony
possible and because the thing that
pursues is eternal it can never be
complete not on earth and not in heaven
day the activity of heaven is going to
be an activity but you have to stop and
mark the milestones and a big milestone
is when somebody finishes the most
intense part of their education and so
we need this ceremony all of us we're
going to invite back as many of the
underclassmen as possible to be around
here and we're going to make it great
and I urge you to go to trouble to come
back for it you seniors we are going to
go to trouble now we have reason to
think that 20% of you can't come back
what about that well we can make that up
too first of all you're missing your
convocation every member of the senior
class is invited to any future
convocation and you can march in your
robe with the seniors of that year and
it won't quite be the same as marching
with your close friends on the other
hand you can feel superior to them their
underclassmen and there'll be a pleasure
in that I hope you enjoy it and if you
do come back for convocation let us know
so we can recognize you the second thing
is you're invited to any if you can't
come to this one you're invited
to any commencement in the future and
you can have the same advantage over
those graduating that year and you can
walk with them and March with them and
we will help pay your expenses back here
if you don't come for this commencement
in other words all of you seniors have a
$500 credit from the college for travel
expenses to get yourself back here for
some ceremony and that's a we don't like
wait we used to sell petrol scholarships
and that was a really crazy idea I was
in the 19th century tuition was $6 and
if somebody paid the $6 they could
present a certificate and come to
Hillsdale College for free and we had a
few of those presented over the years
and we always give them the current
inflated value of that thing and that
means we give them something but I can't
quite give it all to them but this is
perpetual you just have to write us a
letter and tell us and come because I
said and it's true that commencement is
not just for the seniors it means that
your attendance is not just for yourself
I urge you to come if you can come I
think it's an obligation for the rest of
us for everybody everybody for everybody
that's the way it works
I say worried about the fall term oh and
commencement too I mean there's some
chance that we may have to delay the
commencement yet again Boston College I
think it is at Boston University one of
those two has announced it won't be
having in-person classes in the fall I
personally think there is no
justification for that I think that we
are doing unprecedented things in the
name of some statistics that are
uncertain and the most serious experts
disagree about them and life is for the
live
and you got to live and being confined
to quarters
is a serious exercise of governmental
authority and that's supposed to come
from us so we're gonna do commencement
on July 18th and if we can't we're gonna
look for another day and if that doesn't
work another day until we find the day
that's the best day that's available and
we won't fail to do it except for two
circumstances one is if it's illegal
we're not quite I say quite to civil
disobedience yet if it's illegal or if
there are circumstances that make it
apparent that it's dangerous to us and
the people around us and we'll be
watching that and when we start back in
the fall we're going to be watching the
circumstances we've bought for Clorox
machines cost some money takes months to
get them but they should be here by next
fall and you can fog a room in five
minutes and enter it in 20 minutes and
it will be sanitary and we'll fog every
room in the place if we have to twice a
day and then the place if it needs it is
going to be a wash and hand sanitizer
people will be selling it on the black
market there'll be so much of it around
and masks and everything we need right
and we will be making plans as we have
not stopped making plans since all this
started to have College that's what
we're supposed to do
it's a sublime thing to get to do we're
going to be determined and I'll say one
last thing if you spent all the money in
the world saving a life in one scale of
values the life is worth that but if you
did do that every other everybody else
would starve in a week right
so it turns out that that's not open to
us it's one of the trials of life that
we get sick and die
and the question is can we carry on and
it means it's a judgment to do all this
and I doubt the truth of the judgment
but I don't claim that I know and so we
are obeying the judgment and we'll
unless I get a lot more angry than I am
and the board would have to go along
with me I guess and these guys but
remember we must be determined about
this because you just get to live once
and the living is the preparation for
heaven you need to do it well I want to
conclude what I have to say by
mentioning that this is a blessing what
we have here do you see that it makes us
think about the fundamentals of our
activity harder do you see that it's
clearer by the deprivation the power of
the connections we have it makes it
plain that this is valuable to be
treasured to be fought for we have a
right to do it
not many people choose to do it these
days but the ones who do they find a
sublime way of living because they have
carried out the activity of trying to
find out what living is for and if you
do find the answer to that it would have
to be an eternal answer and that means
it would have to go on in heaven as on
earth and we get to see all of that the
senior class this is our hundred seventy
fifth year it's my 20th at the college
we're not celebrating those things
properly but we will because this senior
class the class of 2020
is going to be singular in the whole
history of the college and we will write
about it we will explain how we kept our
daughters up and we had our spirit about
us and we worked and we remained what
we're supposed to be so I think we
should also be grateful for this
even if it makes us angry because we can
overcome this which is precisely the
thing we are called to do
the Emily Daughtry award dr. e Doherty I
always get it wrong he's given by an
anonymous gift from the mother of Susan
McNair and it's given in the fall for a
junior faculty member in the spring for
a senior faculty member this one is a
senior and spectacular faculty member he
doesn't get to be here of course well I
guess he could have come I don't know
what's the limit on the numbers Tim oh
look we have exactly ten do we amazing
amazing somebody thought about that not
i but it's Dave Stewart from the history
department Dave has been here since 1993
he taught at Ohio State and Otterbein
college he got his undergraduate degree
in history and chemistry at Eastern
Nazarene his MA and PhD in from Ohio
State in early modern European history
he's one of our best faculty members in
two senses he's one of the most devoted
teachers he gets the closest to the kids
that anybody gets and then there's a
feature of him that I've only discovered
in reaching the recent years because he
doesn't he doesn't talk all that much at
least when he's around me but lately
more and I discovered that he is a man
of intense an elevated practical
judgment he fears things out and he
shows how to make them work we're gonna
have a a program in Museum Studies if as
soon as somebody gives the money Oh
money after this I'll do that somebody
as soon as somebody gives the money and
he designed it and brought me a budget
and the
it was excellent and it was also brief
and clear the whole plan and in the
history department Mark and his
colleagues say that they don't know how
they carry on without Dave
because he does so much work and doesn't
ask for anything so he's one of our most
valued colleagues and so please join me
in thanking and celebrating Dave Stewart
the big guy here is the chairman of
Dave's department and maybe I'll
persuade Dave to take a picture with me
sometimes to mark this and we'll get
mark there too in a normal year both the
recipient and the department get a check
but we're not no actually we are doing
that we just don't have the checks today
the department okay all the news is
about college has gone broke and so I'll
say a word about that Hillsdale College
is very sound we're not gonna go broke
there's a few reasons for that one of
them is this chapel is really beautiful
and it was very expensive and it's paid
for
there's an old wise man in the stock
market business John Templeton and he
always said after a crash he said the
lesson is don't buy stock with borrowed
money we believe don't build buildings
with borrowed money and so we've just
been rated by Forbes I don't actually
believe the rating but I really like it
they did a big study of GPAs for college
financial GPAs for colleges nine hundred
and sixty some private colleges and you
know one hundred and seventy seven of
them I reckon number Forbes judges to be
in danger of collapse they get D's in
their grade point average 34 get a
pluses
and of the 34:11 get the highest grade
point average which turns out to be four
point four five and we are one of those
eleven there was Stanford and such
Harvard doesn't get that what are they
worth anyway actually they've got so
much money I always say that they could
lend money to the Lord and so I don't
really fully believe this but I do like
it and the reason I mentioned it today
is I want you to know we are going to
carry on that's what we do and there is
no adversity that make us surrender that
we will carry on and right now we have
the means and if it comes in the future
that we don't have the means then we
will find them professor of the year is
chosen by the senior class they do a
grand job of that and they did this time
Lee Baron and chemistry professor is
going to give her speech by tape and I
have watched it and it is beautiful
you're going to enjoy it enjoy it I will
tell you about her that she's these
professor of chemistry and Savona
professor of natural science she went to
undergraduate school at Wittenberg
masters PhD University of Michigan she's
been at Hillsdale since 1989 she has won
the Emily Daughtry award she's the
faculty advisor to the lamplighters into
Sigma Pi and here's what she says about
the student she's very eloquent on the
subject of the students they're
hard-working trustworthy honest
respectful and collegial and collegial
means she goes on to say serious
partnership between student and teacher
everyone bringing something to the table
and everyone taking as much or more away
she says she counts at her chief
blessing to be a part of the lives of
for her students she's a teacher in the
full sense
I will tell you that she's a very
expressive woman and her expressions
heavily involve her hands and we'll see
in the tape if she waves her hands
around but if she doesn't it will be
unnatural and and her closest students
will probably have trouble understanding
her because it's like watching sim
afford go on and I miss seeing that
right now she doesn't do it around me
very much but around you she really just
stick you lates Lee Baron professor of
the year and God bless you all
Thank You dr. Arnn for the kind
introduction and welcome to all of you
who are joining us today imagine
yourself at a lively gathering around a
warming fire in a toga in Greece in
approximately 400 BC have you ever
wondered what it would be like to be
part of those conversations to ponder
with the ancients questions such as what
is the universe and the basic building
blocks therein or what is matter as a
chemist I am particularly fascinated
with helis ipis and his student
Democritus formulated their ideas that
matter was composed of atoms around 400
BC atoms of small indestructible spheres
of various sizes and shapes obviously
this is not how we understand atoms
today but it was an idea that survived
for centuries it boggles my mind or to
have been there when Plato proposed his
job geometric forms to represent the
elements of the universe to have been
part of the conversation when Aristotle
who was known as a key observer over the
world proposed his four earthly elements
fire earth air water and a four as well
as the fifth element the ether because
heavenly bodies were not made of earthly
material he's ancient Greek philosophers
not only pondered what is matter but why
does it matter they wrestled with such
questions as if we exist in this world
and this is the way it is how hot we
live within it what does it mean to be a
human being of character what makes the
good life they were trying to discern
the composition of the universe through
direct observation and logical
deductions while seemed simultaneously
trying to answer fundamental questions
about being human
in this world and discovering their
place within it these ideas about the
natural world did not develop in a
vacuum but through interaction
conversation and within a framework of
being a person of virtue and character
these philosophers were not only asking
what is this world within which we live
but also why does it matter
their ideas were foundational to the way
we do science today as they influenced
philosopher scientists such as the cart
and bacon although ultimately decart's
rationalism and Bacon's empiricism
became two different approaches to
exploring the natural world they both
were still pondering the same things as
the Greeks what is matter and why does
it matter for them these questions were
not separate but rather part of a
cohesive whole as they were men of both
reason and faith they did not view their
exploration of the natural world and
their faith as two opposing approaches
to searching for truth but rather
perspectives that actually work together
to enhance our understanding of the
universe in a synergistic way they were
interested in ways to investigate the
world around them as philosopher
scientists while simultaneously viewing
their findings within the framework of
their faith in my personal experience
this has often been the case the more I
understand science and the natural world
the more I see the majesty of God's
creation the questions about what is the
world that are often addressed by
science seemed to be intertwined with
questions such as why is it this way
or how we to live within it as a chemist
for over 60 years I got my first
chemistry kit at five and a person of
faith for as long as I can remember I
have noticed that scientific discoveries
often confirm and support things that I
already know to be true from my faith
for example the impact of gratitude on
health and wellness
according to the ancient philosophers
gratitude is one of the virtues that is
if it were cultivated would lead to
strength of character and a good life
scientific discoveries have shown that
two neurotransmitters in the brain the
chemical serotonin and dopamine when
released improve your mood your
willpower and your motivation these
feel-good molecules have been shown to
be released when you just try to think
of something that you're grateful for
you don't even have to identify the real
item the real reason to be up for why
you're thankful for this to happen
interestingly spiritual and religious
activities have been shown to be
associated with the thickening of the
brains cortex and a 76 percent decrease
in major depression in dolts whose
parents also suffered from the disease
in other words increased religiosity
leads to better mental health once again
the scientific evidence expands my
understanding confirms what I have
experienced and strengthens my face
through faith I have learned to see
beauty in the world around me and to be
grateful to God for the many blessings
in my life no matter what the
circumstances it is defined how I ought
to live my faith is the framework within
which I function as a scientist and a
human being it guides me to continually
see how the answers to questions from
both perspectives are able to interact
to create one cohesive whole in light of
the recent events and our current
situation one might ask is it still
important that we study our disciplines
to pursue our callings to strive to be
people of character to search for truth
is any of this relevant does it matter
it seems clear to me that it matters now
more than ever although it might be
tempting to
that are approaching this problem from a
single perspective such as science or
prayer in reality it will require the
combination of many perspectives working
together we need scientists and people
from all disciplines who understand the
synergistic way knowledge reason and
faith interact who bring knowledge and
passion for understanding the science
will work collaboratively with people
from many different specialties toward a
common goal and have the strength of
character necessary to make the
decisions that are difficult and often
required one such person comes to mind
dr. Francis Collins who recently did an
interview about Cove in 19 dr. Collins
is a well-known respected scientist who
was the head of the human genome project
one of two scientific research endeavors
that we're working on discovering the
nucleic acid instruction book that is
within our DNA he is currently the
director of the NIH otherwise known as
the National Institute of Health
although the majority of the interview
focused on what we have learned about
the virus and what we should do to
address this pandemic it became apparent
that he was not making any of his
decisions within a vacuum but rather
through many conversations with a number
of experts in various fields throughout
each day dr. Collins who is deciding
which theories projects and clinical
trials to run recognizes the necessity
of these conversations - making the
right decisions but more importantly he
also knows that these decisions need to
occur within a larger framework this
became apparent when dr. Collins
answered the question is there a limit
on how much of the public's money we
should spend on one human life dr.
Collins replied when it comes to the
dollars and the sons you know I am a
Christian I do pay close attention
the way in which Jesus in all his
parables and in all the ways he lived
his life emphasized the value of every
human life and to say okay this just
passed way too much and that next
seventy year old we just got to let him
go I can't go there as a Christian and
probably partly because I'm a physician
I don't think most people would feel all
that comfortable with that trade-off dr.
Collins's answers throughout the
interview Illustrated a knowledge and
passion for his science the need for the
conversations with others of different
expertise to understand the problem and
the importance of that ethical framework
to guide that discovery the expertise of
many of from a variety of different
disciplines and perspectives is what
we're going to need to navigate such
complex issues as we're facing with
today at Hillsdale College our goal is
to equip you for participating in the
conversations required to navigate
through the issues of life and to do
that the journey goes beyond what we
teach you in the classroom it exists in
the time you spend figuring out what you
study why it's your passion and how to
integrate all these ideas within a
larger framework you are in a group of
colleagues who are all searching for
truth from their perspective of they're
very disciplined toes and discipline
each contributing to the conversation
each bringing their expertise and
experiences to the discussion the casual
conversations before and after class in
the hallway over a meal the study
session conversations when you're trying
to understand a difficult concept the
late-night spontaneous conversations and
the dorm are all important to being at
Hillsdale they are what has been missing
since we are no longer together here and
interacting as a community of course we
are still helping you learn and gain
understanding as we complete the
semester in every possible way
including
zooom classrooms it's just not the same
the interchange of ideas as we teach and
challenge each other to grow in
knowledge reason character faith is
necessary ideally this fall we will be
able to be back here together in
community finding our passions gaining
the knowledge to pursue them and having
our conversations for those of you who
will not be returning in the fall our
seniors remember the importance of these
ideas relationships and conversations
that challenge and help you grow while
you were at Hillsdale thank you seniors
for the many times you've included me in
these conversations for I am certain
that they have changed me and allowed me
to grow in knowledge character and faith
remember to the countless hours you
wrestled with the challenging idea or
problem to grow in knowledge and
understanding remember the many
opportunities you had to debate what you
believe and why you believe it use this
knowledge to follow your calling to be a
person of character to discern in each
moment the best way to live as you
graduate from Hillsdale and begin to
pursue the next phase in your life
remember as it says in Joshua 1:9 be
strong and courageous do not be afraid
do not be dismayed for the Lord your God
is with you do not forget to keep
learning having those conversations
searching for truth being grateful and
praying because it matters thank you
please stand for the benediction and now
may the god of peace who brought again
from the dead our Lord Jesus Christ's
the great Shepherd of the Sheep by the
blood of the eternal covenant equip you
for every good work to do his will
working in us that which is well
pleasing in his sight and the blessing
of our Lord Jesus Christ God his father
and the Holy Spirit be with us all and
remain with us evermore
amen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]